but keep in mind that just weeks ago
these very same morons we're calling
Trump a puppet of Saudi Arabia but wait
Saturday BIA wants the u.s. to stay in
Syria does that make sense no and so
after a while you start to suspect the
Trump's real crime isn't being a puppet
of the Saudis or Putin it's refusing to
be a puppet of permanent Washington
that's what they really hate Douglas
McGregor has been around all this for a
very long time he's a retired US Army
colonel he's the author of the book
margin of victory and he joins us
tonight
so colonel I consider you a trustworthy
source of information on these questions
do you think it's an impeachable offense
to withdraw our troops from Syria well
of course not that's ridiculous nonsense
look you've just done a great job of
explaining why President Trump's
decision was really a brilliant decision
first of all President Trump for the
first time made a decision to withdraw
forces without consulting his inner
circle by the way this is the same inner
circle that has sabotaged every policy
action that that President Trump has
tried to initiate has obstructed the
American first agenda from day one so
thank goodness he's not talking to them
secondly he's struck a blow for the
American people against the warfare
State what you just showed on television
is what we like to refer to as the
Washington Unipart II these are the
people on your famous ship that's
sinking right now these are the
individuals lobbyists legislators the
retired senior officers media these are
the individuals that want to cultivate
conflict and keep forces mired
everywhere but as you say leave our
southern border our borders our
territorial waters effectively open so
Donald Trump has done a great service
because he's brought all of this out
into the open and he needs to remember
something when Richard Nixon did
something similar and ended the Vietnam
War and pulled our troops out under the
best circumstances that he could get he
was not only re-elected when he went to
his inauguration he had a 68% approval
rating that's where Donald Trump is
headed with the American people forget
the people in washing
and the people that you just showed on
the television two quick questions is I
notice in all the coverage in the last
two days no one has made an explicit
case for what the point of staying in
Syria would be I mean they make these
sort of broad claims we can't help Putin
or the Iranians but no one ever gets up
and says okay we're gonna be there for
six years are going to achieve these
three things is there is there a case
for it no absolutely not in fact the
good news is that the Russians the
Iranians the Syrian government will do a
very fine job of absolutely annihilating
what remains of Isis the other point is
that we were in a position in northern
Syria where we were extremely vulnerable
remember we always had light troops
there they were always under threat of
attack we were waiting for another
Beirut bombing to occur between the
Turks the Iranians the Kurds and so
forth and by the way the Israelis if
they want to go in there and attack
anything that they think is a is a
danger to their security they can do so
they're free to do so we're out of the
way yeah amen and and last question and
I don't want to be too cynical and I
don't I'm not a conspiracy nut I take
things at face value but would it shock
you if in the next couple of weeks or
months Assad used chemical weapons
against his people once more and lo and
behold we can't leave Syria would that
surprise you well look let's hope that
President Trump has learned from
previous experience and we don't have to
go down that road again the good news is
and he's got some momentum now he can
make profound change he can get rid of
all of these people in the White House
and the Department of Defense who were
against him and against his policies he
needs to seize this opportunity and do
precisely that very smart Colonel burger
thank you very much for coming on it's
great to see you